hello everyone long time no see my name
is mayuko and welcome back to my channel
so today's video I just wanted to
provide kind of an update on what's been
going on in my life it sounds so cheesy
to say that because it's becomes this
whole big thing but I did want to
actually just provide an update about
things because I haven't on this YouTube
channel which is like my main place that
y'all find me on the internet and I'm
just gonna come out and say it uh I got
a software engineering job I am back as
a software engineer full-time I
mentioned this on social media like a
couple months ago already but I'm three
months into this job yeah I just kind of
wanted to talk about it because if
you've noticed it's definitely impacted
like my posting schedule and how much I
post on here because I'm no longer doing
content creation full time so yeah I
wanted to talk about it and just kind of
let you all in on where I'm at how I'm
doing what's been going on and kind of
provide also an update for the future
first and foremost I got a new software
engineering job back again as an iOS Dev
and I started at the end of July so I'd
actually been thinking about going back
to software engineering for a while
maybe since like
Springtime is when I started thinking
about it seriously and specifically
there was like a couple of reasons why I
wanted to go back there was like a few
things that I really missed about
software engineering the first thing
which I think influenced my decision the
most probably is that I just really
missed building stuff with code after I
left my job at Netflix in January of
2020 I was doing this like creating
content full-time and I did that
basically for two and a half years which
was so fun I got to make so many great
videos really got to see what it was
like to own my own business and stuff
but there was just something very
special that I missed about building
things with code the other thing that I
really missed was working on a team I
have a small team of people that I work
with for all of this kind of stuff but
there was something about working in
like a product tech software engineering
team that I really missed collaboration
of like many different roles coming
together and just like having co-workers
who are invested in the work as much as
you are was also something that I
the other thing that I really missed was
just like not being the solely
responsible person for whether a
business was successful or not like I'm
not gonna lie I really liked doing like
content creation full time and I still
am doing content creation to some extent
I'll get into that later but not being
the like only one responsible for
getting stuff done was also something
that I really missed that's the thing
about like being your own business
person like if you don't do it it
doesn't get done there's no one else who
can kind of like fill it in for you
unless you grow your business
intentionally that way which I wasn't
doing so yeah I really miss that and
definitely like as a result the steady
paycheck of having a salary was
something that I missed as well so yeah
a number of reasons why I miss software
engineering and a good opportunity
happens to come up I took it I thought
that I would kind of continue making
videos alongside this job but I haven't
been like I thought that I would balance
YouTube with like working better than I
did because I've done it before like
before I made the jump to content
creation full time I was doing a
full-time software engineering job
alongside making videos but truthfully I
haven't really been making videos
because I haven't felt the urge to I
just haven't
wanted to and something that I noticed
was just like the break has been really
really nice I'm not gonna lie and I just
kind of let this happen very naturally I
wasn't like planning on taking a break
or anything per se I just knew that I
wasn't going to be able to post like
weekly videos like I was before but I
realized upon reflection there's a
couple of reasons why this happened and
really it all comes down to like yes
this work is like so entirely rewarding
but it is really freaking tough I'm not
gonna lie I feel like this was like my
first time being a creative person even
though we're all inherently creative in
our own ways and stuff and it shows up
in different ways but just like really
doing something that was completely out
of my comfort zone that was very
different challenged me in a lot of ways
and I think there were a couple of
themes here and the first one for me is
that creative work for me is like
inherently personal I do a lot of public
introspection on this channel I talk a
lot about my life and what's going on in
my mind but it is a lot of work and it's
really difficult to do this so publicly
and so vulnerably
vulnerably
in a vulnerable way
and at a certain point I I realized I
was reaching a point where I was just
like I just I need to chill I need to
take a break from that definitely I've
grown so much because that's just the
way that I make content and that's the
type of content that I created done so
much disrespecting and learning about
myself and going through so much growth
but I also just kind of needed to just
like
slow down and like gain some balance in
that and then alongside the whole
creative work is inherently personal
there's a lot of like things about
creative work that I was like learning
on the go that I'm still kind of trying
to figure out how exactly to do well
things like being able to constantly
refill the creative well so that I'm
always inspired and then I can always
take that and make that into creative
work is something that I found really
difficult to do and then also because my
work is inherently personal it kind of
started feeling like the life that I was
experiencing was being turned into some
sort of product that's something that I
heard L Mills talk about in a video that
she posted recently which really kind of
like strip a chord with me so there was
like a lot of challenges that I was like
working through constantly about stuff
and there were really fun problems to
solve like I definitely again have grown
so much from it but I did get to a point
where I was just like okay
this is great but like let's
chill for a little bit like let's not
have this tied to whether I make income
or not because now it feels like I have
to do all that in order to survive which
was like really weird mental state to be
in I just got myself into a place where
I was too desperate to be creative to
feel like I could make anything super
good or fun and that's an important part
like I realized I needed my work to be
fun and the work wasn't really fun
anymore and that was kind of like a big
red flag to me so I was just like okay
Something's Gotta change so yeah in an
interesting way the answer turned out to
be let's go back into software
engineering because you know how to do
that and that was fun and maybe now that
you've taken a break from software
engineering and you go back to it you'll
find new things that you like about it
that you previously didn't and yeah
honestly I've been very pleasantly
surprised since going back into software
development I'm at a really tiny startup
with about 10 people it's fully remote
it's kind of like in the biotech space a
little bit doing iOS development and I
am I'm so surprised at how much I'm
having fun coding I think I've said on
the channel before that like I never
really enjoyed the coding part of
software development I liked being able
to make stuff and collaborate with
people on a team to do things but it was
never the coding that was it for me but
like ever since I started this job I'm
really enjoying the coding and I think
this is the first time I have in like
ever which is a huge surprise maybe I
just needed that really long break or
something but I'm really enjoying like
pumping out code and like solving coding
problems other than that it's been
really nice to work on a team it's been
nice to have a lot of predictability in
my tastes it's nice to have a salary
it's nice to be able to work on a thing
with other people and we all bring our
skills together to the table to like
make that thing happen but it's all kind
of external to us granted I've never
worked at a startup this tiny before so
there's definitely some challenges that
I'm experiencing because life is not all
roses and there's always going to be
tough times no matter what happens so
definitely feeling some early startup
growing pains and stuff sometimes but
like it's just been a really nice change
to go from content creation full time
and making videos for you all to doing
what I do now and it's just really funny
because I just thought I would never go
back to software engineering but here I
am and I'm liking it a lot and so I
wanted to make this video to just talk
about that because I don't really feel
like I've failed as a YouTuber or a
content creator or a business owner but
I've just needed to adjust and pivot
based on my life
priorities and circumstances and things
that I wanted to do which is totally
okay like I've I've actually eased into
this transition better than I thought
and I'm really happy and so in thinking
about kind of like how do I want to do
YouTube but from now on I'm not really
sure to be quite honest I'm not really
like making any hard and fast decisions
right now because I don't know like I
don't want to quit entirely I also am
not going to commit to doing weekly
videos still because that's just not
really in my heart and you know maybe in
the future I'll have like a full-fledged
comeback or something like that I'm just
kind of leaving it open to the
opportunity to be what it needs to be
what it needs to be based on what I want
to do so I guess the answer is like
we'll see I'm also writing a book in
Japanese to help Japanese people come to
the states and work in Tech and
introducing kind of like a lot of
English language Concepts that are
commonly used in the tech industry and
that's coming out next year so there's
still a lot of projects that are
happening behind the scenes just like
video creation is maybe not like the
front and center of my mind right now so
yeah announcements will still continue
to come and they'll happen here on my
channel on my social media platforms and
stuff and so I'm still around and
speaking of social media I am kind of
also like reeling it back a little bit
just as a personal decision because I
want to have better boundaries and a
better relationship to like internet
life so I'm not posting as much but I'm
still here so yeah that's the update
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate all the support that I've
received ever since I started my channel
and I hope that you continue to be
around and be here and say hello and
maybe watch some of my older videos that
I'm so proud to have made and stuff so
yeah thank you so much for letting me do
this and be here and express my
gratitude and yeah all all the things so
I really really really appreciate it and
thank you I guess uh I'll see you around
bye